welcome Roger stone author of the brand
new book the making of the president
2016 this is your fifth book but a
really special one for you because you
know the subject so well and have known
for decades so I'm gonna start with my
first question how do you think
President Trump is doing I think he's
doing fine in view of the fact that he's
had no honeymoon which has been pretty
traditional for our presidents no two or
three weeks of goodwill from the other
party and that his election was such a
shock to the political system he's
sticking to his agenda which is the key
thing I think he's making progress on
issues and all these other contra temps
about his Twitter feed and so on I
really think that's a sideshow that the
voters not too interested in the Twitter
feed though has become a big part of his
presidency the media focuses on it
becomes a subject on talk shows it's
almost you know as big a part of his
presidency as is when he takes to the
podium how do you consider that in the
grand scheme of things in terms of his
success as a president going forward do
you think this will help him could
potentially hurt him if you were on his
staff would you advise them to cool it
on the Twitter or do you think maybe
it's a good thing it's his ability to
communicate directly to the voters
without the filter of the mainstream
media or even the alternative media so I
think it's an extremely valuable tool as
he likes to say it's like owning a
newspaper without the debt you can reach
16 million people in a flash so I would
urge him to keep tweeting because I
think it is a valuable tool the
mainstream media Nashes their teeth
about it because it allows him to
communicate direct I don't think they
like that they like to interpret that
said I do think that he is going to be
Donald Trump he's not going to change
this whole idea that he is going to
become more presidential he could become
more diplomatic I don't think that's how
he got elected people like him because
he's blunt because he's genuine because
he's uncoated unscripted what you see is
what you get
that's what we have elected but I will
go back to referring to your book will
you talk about your departure from the
campaign in part because you differed
with strategy look like you wanted a
little bit more discipline maybe a
little less of trumping Trump and more
campaign discipline how does that you
know how do you take that and square it
with your view now do you think that he
does need more discipline now in the way
that you felt was needed during the
campaign doesn't really matter what I
think the truth is I left the campaign
but never stopped being a Trump
supporter or a cheerleader for a couple
reasons one my book the Clintons war on
women was about to publish and I didn't
want anyone to say oh that's a Trump
project or a Trump funded project or a
Trump directed project because it wasn't
secondarily and I was wrong about this I
wanted him to run a more traditional
campaign in terms of the traditional
tools of campaigning polling analytics
paid advertising and so on he eschewed
all those things I didn't think you
could win doing that he was right I was
wrong
he's a phenomena unto himself I'm not
sure would work for any other candidate
but it did work for Donald Trump well in
your book you describe him as using that
unconventional approach to have this
unprecedented victory and as you said it
was different than the approach you were
talking about can you talk about in your
book and how you describe how he was
able to overcome not having a
traditional approach yet still winning
in these states that Republicans haven't
been able to win and where he didn't was
spend the same amount of money as the
Democrats or even the Republican machine
when he was running in the primary in
your estimation how was it that he was
able to get around the need for all
those traditional approaches this
election was different than any other
presidential election I've been involved
in and I this would be my tenth
presidential campaign this was the
election in which the tipping point was
finally reached in terms of the
mainstream media losing their monopoly
on the dissemination of political
information obviously in the 60s when
there was only three networks the
destruction of Barry Goldwater was
pretty easy
three networks chimed in and good old
Barry was done a warmonger a maniac a
lunatic of course later when he gets
back to the Senate he becomes quite
revered in this election the tipping
point had been reached largely I think
because of technological reasons meaning
people now getting their news on their
handheld device no longer getting it
from a television set and therefore the
mainstream media the three networks the
two cable networks really lost their own
their ratings start to drop and more and
more voters are getting their
information from alternative sources
some of them conservative alternative
sources some of them just alternative
sources so yes info wars.com Breitbart
Daily Caller townhall those are all
important and Trump I think realizes
this when nobody else does the other key
factor is for the first time ever I
think voters begin to realize that big
media is in bed with big government and
the big establishment that the three
networks and the two cable outlets are
reinforcing the narrative of the
mainstream media and voters for the
first time are skeptical used to be if
you saw something on TV it must be true
now I think the opposite is true you see
something on CNN and you wonder why I
wonder if that's really true
so I think those two changes one of them
technologically-driven made the big
difference for down front so you look at
the situation now where he's having poll
numbers that are showing you with lower
approval rating again you have the
saturation by the media that's I think
pretty overwhelmingly negative about
president Trump's so far do you think
that still the media is having a pretty
big impact on his presidency right now
despite his ability to reach out to
people through these other avenues well
of course a lot of the polls that show
him with a low approval rating are the
same exact polls that showed Hillary
Clinton winning easily so their sample
is questionable one of the problems in
this campaign has been the polls across
the board were largely wrong some of
them I think through an honest mistake
others because they were
in other words they're based on an
assumption that the turnout this past
presidential election was going to be
identical to four years ago the same
number of blacks and whites and
Christians and Jews and women and men
and younger and older and so on that was
a false premise there was an assumption
that Hillary Clinton would both pull out
the same number of african-americans and
get the same percentage of them that
Barack Obama got not possible so this
explains why the polls were so off there
was a anecdotal information to the
contrary look at the crowds Trump was
drawing now look at the crowds Hillary
was having trouble drawing look at the
overwhelming presence of Trump
supporters and social media the media
tended to discount all that counting on
the pollsters so perhaps the president's
approval rating is higher today than
some of the polls are showing on the
other hand the negative barrage does
continue and it's incumbent on the
president frankly to out communicate his
critics he still has the bully pulpit
and he can still do that can you talk
about your early introduction of
President Trump and you talked about in
the book how you saw him as potentially
becoming a president someday a very long
time ago can you talk about what that
what happened there and where you got
that feeling the first person to imagine
a trump presidency was not me but was
former President Richard Nixon I was
working for Nixon doing political chores
in his post presidential years and he
met Donald Trump in George
Steinbrenner's box at Yankee Stadium and
they hit it off and he called me the
next day and he said well I met your man
I got to tell you he's got it he
couldn't really go all the way he said
that
and and then days later he dropped a
note which I reproduce in the book to to
Donald Trump
that said this is so typical of Nixon's
circum location mrs. Nixon he said saw
you on the Mike Douglas Oh show and
thought you were superb
and she says if you ever run for public
office you will win because you're a
winner and mrs. Nixon knows about these
things so well of course he was talking
about himself in his own judgement not
long after that President Nixon and
Donald Trump spent a weekend together
they went for a charitable event in
Houston Texas they essentially
barricaded themselves in a hotel suite
and spent hours together talking
geopolitics and Nixon said Trump just
fired questions out of one after another
wanting to know about Brezhnev about the
Russians the Chinese really around the
world tour so the men hit it off and it
was Nixon who first saw the potential
for a trump presidency I wanted him to
run as early as 1988 I was determined of
his presidential exploratory committee
in 2000 I was a consultant to his
exploratory effort in 2012 but in
retrospect 2016 was the right year why
is that
well I think it was the perfect storm I
think it was not only the tipping point
had been reached for alternative media
as we discussed and that's an important
factor but also after eight years of
Barack Obama the American people were
really ready for something different in
the 40 years I've been involved in
politics I've never seen the voters in
this angry or this sour were this
disillusioned moved they're just totally
fed up with politicians political
institutions big media big government
they're ready for something radical
ready for an outsider and Donald Trump
fit the bill perfectly did he discuss
with you his plans to run this time
around before he made the decision or
how he was trying to weigh whether to do
it or not yes really
within days of Mitt Romney losing but
before the end of 2012 Donald Trump had
his attorneys go to the US Patent and
Trademark Office and trademarked the
slogan make America great again he told
me on New Year's Day of 2013 that he was
definitely running in 2016 and that he
had taken these steps
at the trademark office I was certain
that he would run throughout the entire
year and therefore the media columnist
slike McKay Coppins for example and
others this constant hectoring that
Trump will never really run he's just
burnishing the brand this is a publicity
he's a publicity hound this is a
head-fake i knew through the entire year
that he would really run what was
different this year though because he
has thought about it before not carried
through I think his business was in the
right place he was in the position to
turn over his business to his older
children I don't think there were any
more mountains to climb in the real
estate industry he'd really kind of done
it all with the hotel now in Washington
DC being a new crown jewel and the Trump
enterprises he realized that that the
country was also in the right place I
would go back to something he told Oprah
Winfrey 20 years ago when she said
Donald do you think you'd ever run for
public office would you ever run for
president and he said no I don't think
so unless things get so bad that I have
no choice remember that interview that's
where we are today he's not running
because he wants the title he's not
running because of the great house and
the great plane you got he's already got
a a great place in in Manhattan and a
great place in Palm Beach he's already
got an airplane that's on a par with Air
Force One he's not doing this to be
somebody he already was somebody when he
ran for president he's doing it because
the country is in trouble and he thinks
he can save it what do you make of the
response to his presidency by the people
who do not support him the protests have
trickled down even to the local level
for state representatives who are not
Democrat what do you make of the
response the big protests that took
place right after the inauguration and
what does that mean for his success as a
president is a way they can just
permanently hobble him by just trying to
obstruct at every turn or should they
have a greater voice because the popular
vote
went to Hillary Clinton what do you make
of it well some of the demonstrations of
course are agate prop they're paid for
and orchestrated others I think are
sincere people who have concerns because
they may be buying the caricature of him
that has been painted by some in the
mainstream media the real answer for him
is pretty simple and that is you know
damn the torpedoes full speed ahead
fulfil your agenda if it restores our
nation's economic prosperity or at least
moves in that direction you see an
uptick in jobs you've already seen the
uptick in the market you already seen
the uptick in small business confidence
but if he restores the economy I think a
lot of this will fall away a vibrant
economy would give him the revenues he
needs to address all of our other
problems focusing particularly on
infrastructure Trump is first and
foremost foremost a builder mm-hmm which
is why don't try to convince him the
wall can't be built because it can don't
try to convince them that our inner
cities can't be rebuilt they can if he
will fulfill those promises I think a
lot of this opposition will fall away
it's a tough wish list though because
you need the cooperation of Congress
where you have a lot of Republicans who
are deficit hawks and don't want to run
up a big tab on all these projects which
are going to be very expensive they've
also got healthcare reform tax reform
two major agenda items that you normally
don't see happen even in a single
Congress never mind two big items like
that so he's promised a lot to the
country do you think that he can deliver
and is there any you know hazard for him
having promised so much and then perhaps
not being able to check off every item
well this is precisely why he's using
the executive orders to achieve as much
as he can before turning to a
legislative solution his ability to
circumvent the Congress and go directly
to the people I think is unprecedented
since Ronald Reagan did exactly that
with the Democratic Congress but passing
his initial tax reform I do think the
president should focus on tax reform
particularly his corporate tax cut his
across-the-board tax cut his program
foreign
version I would do that first rather
than dealing with immigration first
because I think that is the the key to
the solution of all the other problems
he's going to have a tough road because
as you point out some Republicans in
Congress are in transient but his
ability to make them feel the heat if he
can't make them see the light by going
right to the people I think is still his
whole card let's talk about the book and
how you came up with the idea for it the
timing of it sounds like you had to
write it pretty quickly when did you
first decide that no there was going to
be a book about his election well I
decided to write a book at the time I
left the campaign because whether or not
he won or whether he lost there was a
book in this frankly I was pretty
confident that he would win through most
of the campaign even in the darkest days
because I noticed his resilience in the
polls in other words let's take for
example his attack on Senator McCain
when many in the mainstream media
thought that was it he was going to be
blown out of the race sure he went down
two or three points and he bounced right
back up same thing happened when he
attacked the judge who was of
mexican-american heritage he took a
small hit in the polls but he bounced
right back I think that's because voters
had bigger issues in mind and they were
going to excuse him
these detours if you will because of his
overall agenda so I think that
resilience always indicated to me that
he could win a close race I didn't think
he had to expand the map and that
opportunity came late but it came the
ability to go into Michigan and
Wisconsin and double down in western
Pennsylvania was where he won this race
I go a step further he got approximately
three percent more of the
african-american vote than Mitt Romney
doesn't sound like much sounds de
minimis but it's the difference between
winning and losing Michigan she also got
less Hillary Clinton she got she got
less the overall turnout was not as
great and he got three percent more
that's the difference between victory
and defeat in Michigan that's the
difference between victory and defeat in
Wisconsin and that's the difference
between victory and defeat in
Pennsylvania just that small incremental
bump up in the african-american vote so
you're in a situation where the race was
so close you can't point to any one
thing that made the difference because
it was so close it was a confluence of
things that made the difference
including his superhuman physical effort
in the clothes
I mean stealing a page from Harry Truman
he barn storms into eight states late
while Hillary Clinton is back in
Chappaqua and her pajamas looking at the
swatches for fabric for the new curtains
in the Oval Office they were very
confident the Hillary Clinton campaign
that they had a victory in front of them
and there are a lot of people in the
media people in Congress people
political observers pollsters who felt
the same way you are among a few who
felt confident that he would win talk
about when you really felt that the tide
had turned for him right before the
election well prior to the FBI director
announcing that he would reopen the
inquiry into Hillary's emails which I
think was the Thursday before the
election he was already gaining at a
pretty fast clip that event merely
accelerated his climb in the beginning
she was sitting still in the polls that
I was tracking but after that she began
to drop slightly that's where you could
see the trajectory so it's the close of
any race when you're examining the polls
it's not where you are that's important
as much as of the direction so for
example if Wednesday in Pennsylvania
you're down five and Friday you're down
three and Sunday you're down one you can
see the direction in the trajectory all
of the polling that I examined the final
weekend which came not only from the
campaign some but the campaign did not
spend extensively on polling whereas
Hillary Clinton polled every time she
burped to test that burp before we did
it
but looking at polling from the state
Republican operations looking for
statewide candidates who were polling
the presidential question looking at an
enormous amount of data be claimed to
became clear to me on Sunday before the
election his timing perfect his
trajectory was almost perfect and he was
on a track to win I became confident at
that point nobody was expecting though
the victories in Wisconsin in Michigan
in Pennsylvania those three were really
considered outliers for him to be able
to pull off were you surprised though
that he was able to get those three
states no because you could you could
see in the polling that they were within
reach you could see that he was gaining
but also he visited all three I mean he
went back and visited all three in the
close where I think Hillary and her
folks must have thought this was in the
back and there were people who thought
that he should have been in Ohio that he
shouldn't have been trying to expand the
map he should have been focusing on the
must-win States what happened at that
level for them to decide to go ahead and
expand rather than just focus on the
areas where he really needed to win by
eventually one like Florida and Ohio I
think a decision was made that they were
both safe and that turned out to be
right Ohio particularly is interesting
because Mitt Romney and John McCain for
that more matter George W Bush spent
tens of millions of dollars and put
forward a very strong effort and none of
them could ever pop Ohio but that's
largely because in the western part of
the state Donald Trump was able to pick
up white moderate working-class Union
Democrats at a rate that neither of
those gentlemen any of those gentlemen
had been able to achieve so Trump pulled
out to about a five point lead in Ohio
and it never dropped Ohio was safe for
him much earlier I really didn't in the
end wasn't a battleground state Florida
was tighter but I think a good decision
was made that the Donald Trump would
carry both in their court therefore he
could afford to spend his time in
Michigan and Wisconsin in Pennsylvania
which was absolutely necessary he could
have carried Ohio in Florida and still
lost without those and of course
Virginia I think was always winnable I
think the Republican National Committee
pulled crucial resources out of there
and interesting which was detrimental he
could have won Virginia which of course
he lost very narrowly you break the book
down into various sections as a campaign
first the primary and then the general
election and you talk about it requiring
sort of two sets of staff for each
depending on you know what the goal they
wanted to achieve so that's a little bit
different how that sort of transition
from primary to general election and you
saw one top campaign staffer leave and
another one coming can you talk about
how that worked and was a little bit
unusual and it certainly worked in his
favor
well don't from decided on a all
communications based strategy early on
in which the rally was the centerpiece
so he made a decision rather than
spending money on paid media he would do
every interview he could possibly Jim
into his schedule and he would go into
the states do these massive rallies
confident that the two cable networks
would cover them wall-to-wall and they
did it's a multi-million dollar campaign
commercial what do you think about it he
did this eschewing organization and
structure and of course while his
primary opponents were spending a
fortune on analytics and phone banks and
polling an organization Trump was going
solely communications and it worked he
so completely dominated the free media
before each primary that it was like
having paid advertising and that worked
fine for that portion of the campaign
when he hit Wisconsin and then
substantially subsequently lost
doublegate contests in North Dakota
Colorado and Louisiana was stolen out
from under a few different formats that
a different format and you were heading
into a convention now in a convention
there's a premium on organization and
structure so for example no one in the
Trump campaign had thought about who
from each state was going to sit on the
rules and the credentials committee
which are crucial
if the nomination was going to be stolen
from from that's where it would happen
that's why I thought he was wise to
bring in my former partner Paul Manafort
who's an expert in convention politics
pulled together a structure ultimately
rout the Cruz people in the Rules
Committee we were prepared to rout them
in the credentials committee senator Ted
Cruz who ran against us Trump in the
prime Last Man Standing so the campaign
needed to change at that juncture and
then it did then in a general election
the campaign needed to change again the
president wisely brought in Steve Bannon
Kelly and Conway and I think that they
were able to retool in time for a
general election campaign but that said
I can tell you Donald Trump didn't
prepare for any of these debates not in
the traditional way with a stand and
acting like Hillary Clinton he knew he
didn't do anything he just he just read
and made notes and calculated and he
went in and I would argue he won every
debate but there's there's lots of
criticism about his performance that he
did not seem prepared or knowledgeable
about some of the issues he he's a
polarizing figure there's always going
to be criticism I the proof is in the
pudding he won the election I thought
one debate you could argue was a
standoff the others which one was that
which to me I think it was probably the
first one the second one frankly he
clinched the debate when she said we
can't trust a man like Donald Trump to
run the Justice Department and he said
because you'd be in jail that was the
beginning of the end well nowadays the
criticism of Trump again is that he's an
outsider and he doesn't understand the
issues because he's never been in
government before people saying well
look now you've got an outsider here
he's doing all these things that maybe
not be good for the country because he
doesn't understand what do you make of
that criticism and and do you think
Trump really can learn on his feet in
the White House well that's very typical
of the Washington establishment it's
like mr. president now that you're here
you have no experience in these things
let us help you what they really mean is
let us
real your your program the Republicans
in the Democrats the elite leadership of
both parties they like the status quo
they like the way things are right now
they fight on television then they all
go out to dinner afterwards and slap
each other on the back it's all about
getting reelected and raising the money
to get reelected my real problem with
the Bush Clinton Bush Obama continuum is
not only had they driven the country
into the gutter not only had they given
us endless war and massive debt and
spending erosion of our civil liberties
an immigration system that leaves our
neighborhoods unsafe trade agreements
that suck the jobs out of the country
and an incoherent foreign policy but
they and their cronies have gotten
extremely rich while doing it so while
they have made the people poorer and
less safe they themselves have made
hundreds of millions of dollars
it's an elitist phenomenon that I think
the voters are fed up with well yeah
Trump is receiving a lot of criticism
about whether there could be conflicts
of interest for him because he is
supposed to be hands-off with his real
estate empire but there's questions
about that how do you think that will
play out do you think that the public
may start to scrutinize him in a
different way and think well wait is he
you know is there a conflict of interest
here or do you still see any problem
there with I'm not selling every sexual
II think one of his greatest strengths
in this election was his independence
the fact that people felt he had so much
money that you couldn't buy him you
didn't there was no use in trying that
he couldn't be bought and he couldn't be
bullied I think that's still the case
I'm satisfied with the way he's
structured his business I think people
are gonna be hard put to find any actual
conflict he I'm sure understands that
after he leaves office he'll have many
opportunities if he wants to make more
money but he's a billionaire how much
more money does he need the important
thing is with that comes the
independence to do some very difficult
controversial things people who talk
about his re-election I think no I don't
see that as a foregone conclusion he may
choose
to run depends on how much he achieves
in four years how much is left to be
achieved what do you think would
influence his decision to not run mm-hmm
a bountiful economy the return of
prosperity but that's the success in
winning what we want to keep doing it
make it may take eight years it may take
four but he's a man of action he's not
going to sit back and let somebody else
set this agenda he's going to set the
agenda I think I'll decide about
re-election based on how much he's
gotten done how much more he has yet to
do he's given up an incredible lifestyle
to do this I mean here's a guy who loves
his family loves his grandchildren he is
really a homebody even when he's in New
York or or Florida he's not out on the
party circuit he loves to play golf
he loves his daily routine there's a
huge sacrifice in this for him just in
terms of lifestyle he's doing it again
not because he needs to be somebody not
because it solves his ego but because he
has an agenda to save the country one of
the hardest parts for transition is to
take your campaign and then transition
into a presidential team he brought
along with him Steve Bannon who you talk
about the book as someone who was needed
to come in for the homestretch of the
general election and to keep Trump
focused and centered
yet now Bannon is sort of criticized and
ridiculed by you know on Saturday Night
Live they depict him as the grim reaper
that he's some you know outlier force
there in the White House that shouldn't
be there you know what do you make of
that criticism and what is how does that
square with what you know about Steve
Bannon personal I think the idea that
been in is Trump's brain or Trump's
Svengoolie is exactly backwards really
in and that's because you've known him a
long time and so what Steve and Donald
Trump have the same worldview that they
are copacetic on issues is not
surprising that's how they became
friends that's how they were attracted
to each other so Crump is not doing
Benin's well been in his doing Trump's
will he's doing the presidents well they
haven't done anything that the president
hasn't talked about in the campaign
Reince Priebus on the other hand
and you know represents establishment
Republicans I'm disgusted by the leaks
coming out of the White House I mean I
understand leaking I've got a fair
amount of it in my day
strategic leaking for a purpose but when
you are leaking to the detriment of your
boss when you are leaking for example
the Washington Post had a leak in which
a White House staffer says the president
is like a clueless child and the New
York Times had a leak that talked about
the president wearing a bathrobe in the
family quarters after hours which I
would hope so because it's pretty drafty
mm-hmm that's not helping the boss that
that's trying to aggrandize yourself by
leaking with and suck up to reporters I
think it comes out of those who are not
Trump loyalists I tell you this they're
not coming from Steve Bennett or
Kellyanne Conway because they are Trump
loyalists so I fear these leaks come
from the establishment Republicans who
seem to dominate most of the Washington
most of the White House staff under
Reince Priebus and they're detrimental
they're unprofessional and they're
hurting the president's not good hmm
what do you think's going to happen
though because he's going to have to
work with establishment people in the
White House with him I mean they could
just undercut his entire presidency then
with leaks and just lack of cooperation
what do you think needs to happen the
best possible reason to hire Trump
people for key positions people whose
loyalty is to Donald Trump people who
supported Donald Trump for the
nomination prior to the convention not
after there are many many qualified
people who were active in this campaign
who have applied and heard nothing being
this enormous rush to hire a Republican
National Committee alum I think it's a
mistake it is interesting to me that
when Jim Baker who was George Bush's
campaign manager was hired to be
President Reagan's chief of staff the
first thing he did was reach out to
high-profile Reaganites like Lyndon off
cigar and faith Whittlesea and others
and hire them for the White House staff
and therefore he didn't Brook the kind
of criticism that you have now
Priebus so you've worked for other
presidents including Richard Nixon could
you talk about the two and if there's
any you said that they spoke at one
point in and while he was living can you
talk about any comparisons between the
two and how they operate it's pretty
early days and Trump's presidency but
there any similarities or differences
you can talk I think there's enormous
similarities between both President
Trump and President Nixon and President
Trump and President Reagan they're
different in the case of of Nixon both
men are brilliant
both men are stubborn when they focus on
a goal you can't get them off of it both
of them are pragmatic Trump is not an
ideologue he is a conservative populist
or a populist with conservative
instincts but above all he's interested
in what works he's interested in
solutions kind of like Franklin
Roosevelt I think he may try something
if it doesn't work he'll stop and try
something else until he solves the
problem so I think they're both they're
both pragmatists and they're both
realists on the other hand Trump is very
much like like Reagan in in terms of his
size I don't mean just his physical size
although they have that in common both
tall and broad-shouldered but there's a
command presence there it's it's more
than charisma it's more than magnetism
but both men fill a room they have a
certain stature that is particularly
strong on television so in that sense I
think Trump is a master communicator as
Reagan was Trump is more interested in
the details than President Reagan was in
that sense he's more like Nixon so I
like to think that he embodies the best
qualities of both that's very
interesting so if you were to make a
call on his performance right now what
would you recommend to him in terms of
if you were on staff but what you'd what
you would what changes you would make or
what you would like to see him do
differently well stick to the agenda
which he's already doing not different
hire more Trump bites I think that is
important that
invest your confidence in people who
share your vision don't hire people who
have a great resume but have never stood
up for trumpism and work for you in the
general election
I think that's generally good advice and
ignore the the carping of the washington
press corps they're never going to get
with the program they're still in shock
about losing the election and don't
forget the alternative media in other
words if you want to reach millions of
people unfiltered interview with
Breitbart interview with The Daily
Caller interview with Infowars
they're reaching millions and millions
of people and you're not going to get
the you're not going to get the the
twist that you'll get from say CNN
should he try to reach out to the people
who voted for Hillary Clinton because
she did win the popular vote is there
some way he's trying to reach out the
best way to reach out to them is to
revitalize our economy and prove your
critics wrong something that Trump said
throughout this campaign where he would
say in a year you'll see you'll be
really happy I'm going to do a good job
I think that's true I think that he will
get a reassessment after a year so
ignore the carping ignore the petty
criticism and stick to your agenda and
remember if you revive the economy if
you renegotiate the trade deals if you
start to rebuild our inner cities just a
one city as an example take Detroit or
Philadelphia and show what can be done I
think he could be one of our greatest
president does he have the skills to
take his business acumen and then
translate it into working in government
such a different skill set you would
argue I suppose Ken do you think he has
the ability to do that he's been a
businessman his whole life the mashed
nations of Washington it's much
different having to work with Congress
there's lots of roadblocks and
frustrations you could say well gee see
it you need to be a talent like LBJ to
be able to work with the Congress these
days everybody's so angry at each other
right yet he has none of that experience
do you see him being able to do that yes
because he's a deal maker he's a
negotiator and you never know how much
of what he says is for the purposes of
negotiate
so for example he's talked about tariffs
on our trading partners I'm not sure
he's really going to do tariffs but I'm
also not sure that he's not it's the
stick now the carrot so either we make a
better deal or I'll be forced to do
tariffs he's doing that so far with with
various but he's but he knows that the
cut in the corporate tax rate would
[ __ ] China and Mexico faster than any
tariffs which is why he needs to put it
in forefront of his program the way he
has worked in the phone
I'm carrier for example and other big
companies to induce them to stay here
it's really worthy of Lyndon Johnson he
really has been jawboning these
executives to get them to stay and
expand I think you're gonna see more of
that now you can argue oh it's only a
thousand jobs here and a thousand jobs
there it's symbolic that he's making the
effort I think is what's important one
of the more interesting parts of your
book is where you talk about him as an
underestimated candidate I mean it was I
guess you could say it's the
understatement of the year he was such
an underestimated candidate how did he
stay confident but I was always amazed
by how confident he remained even though
you know you're right the Washington
media establishment his own party
everybody seemed dead set against him
being the nominee and then dead Sun set
against him being the president I mean
he just seems like an almost impossibly
confident person did you notice that
about him and how do you think that that
played into his victory well he's an
optimist
mm-hmm and he is supremely confident I
think that's one of the things that
appealed to voters um he is a can-do guy
he doesn't think that anything is
impossible we never thought that this
election was impossible even he at the
end I think finally got beat down by the
constant mainstream media saying you
can't win you can't win you can't win
well he told his wife as he said
publicly maybe we may not win tonight
that's about as bad as it got I think it
was momentary nobody could be immune to
the fact that the mainstream media tried
to write him out of the race at least
three times at the end of August they
were saying he
victory was impossible we hadn't even
had a campaign yet so I don't think he
ever lost the faith I always thought
that he thought he would win his
confidence is integral to the makeup of
his personality that's what makes him
Donald Trump well where does it come
from you know that's nothing unusual to
be that confident well I think two
things first of all he has succeeded
beyond his own wildest dreams in terms
of building a a you know an economic
success a business success but also the
experience of coming to the brink of
disaster and fighting your way back that
makes you stronger Trump is a very very
tough guy what faizon what are you
talking about that the problem is that
his bankruptcy okay take it back his
near bankruptcy he never filed for
personal bankruptcy he used bankruptcy
as a legitimate tool for his companies
and of course they emerged from
bankruptcy so he got overextended there
was a crash he survived it not only did
it survive it he came back stronger than
ever
1997 yes roughly this is very much like
say Richard Nixon and Watergate his
career is in tatters but he clauses up
his way back to respectability and he
ends up as an advisor to President
Clinton on matters of foreign policy
that you know are vexing the country
Russia China and so on so that
near-death experience makes you tougher
anybody who doesn't understand how tough
Donald Trump is really doesn't get it in
his personal demeanor he's very likeable
he's a regular guy he's not snobby or
stilted or stiff or formal in any way so
he's a billionaire who's not an elitist
who's not a snob but I think that
experience of coming close to financial
disaster and surviving it has just made
him stronger and more confident talk
about your book your your relationship
goes back decades can you talk about
your first meeting with him and while
your impression was when you first met
President Trump sure I went to New York
in 1979 I was assigned to run New York
New Jersey and Connecticut for former
governor Ronald Reagan's campaign I was
introduced down front by his attorney
the notorious Roy Cohn I went in saw
Cohn and I told him you know I needed
headquarters a Finance Committee
volunteers telephones and so on and he
said what you need is Donald from now
I'll make an appointment for you at
Donald Trump but he's very busy he's not
going to give you much of his time so
make your pitch and get out there's the
you know so I went to see Donald he was
very gracious I said mr. Trump it's a
great honor to meet you he said please
call me Donald after the inauguration
when I said congratulations mr.
president
he said please call me Donald he's an
unassuming guy he's just eminently
likable he has a great sense of humor
he's very funny but what impressed me
that day was his intensity he listened
to everything I had to say and then he
asked four or five very tough questions
and his questions and remember I'm
making the pitch that Ronald Reagan can
get elected president 1979 all of his
questions related to the electoral map
first question he asked me was how do
you get to 270 it's interesting I'm
assuming your man can carry California
which of course he did but how did he
get to 270 interestingly in virtually
every conversation I had with him about
the 1980 presidential campaign and he's
a junkie he loves politics the way you
love sports he would always ask that
same question at the end so give me your
new take on the map where's your 270 so
he's always understood that construct
and I think it was a key part of the
strategy for this campaign he always had
an eye on how to get to 270 electoral
votes his politics have been less
concrete though he is considered at some
phases in his life to be a Democratic
supporter now I mean what are his
politics I think people still wonder
where he is firmly planted politically
if anywhere well prior to his political
activism when he was a businessman and
strictly a businessman
he gave to both parties and he gave to
candidates from both party not uncommon
many of it's very common particularly
for people of his wealth and with a
company as large and with as many
interests New York City is a Democratic
bastion right one has to have great
relationships with the unions in order
to build anything in New York City he's
actually got a lot of union support he's
been always had a great relationship
with the building trades unions he did
leave the Republican Party largely
because he objected to the Iraq war and
he was deeply disappointed in George W
Bush and I was there in those days he
most definitely opposed the Iraq war
because I was opposed to it and we
talked about it and I wrote that at the
time he came back to the republican
party after george w bush was gone he
did briefly switch to the Reform Party
or actually the Independence Party of
New York which is affiliated their
foreign party because Ross Perot and
then Governor Jesse Ventura urged him to
look very seriously at the Reform Party
nomination it's important to note that
the Reform Party was entitled to 58
million dollars worth of matching funds
at the time something they're no longer
entitled to because of the strong
showings of Ross Perot in 92 and 96 so
you had the prospect of running for
president on OPM other people's money
yeah that appealed to Trump the
businessman as you might expect but he
correctly concluded after a really
intense exploration that the country is
not going to elect an independent
president anytime soon that just ballot
access is controlled by the Republicans
and the Democrats working together and
therefore one really has to be a
Republican or a Democrat to win the
election as president he switched back
to the party of his parents and the
party that he spent most of his adult
life in the Republican Party talk about
a little bit of the tensions within the
campaign this was a dramatic moments
early in the campaign between Paul
Manafort who was the face to campaign
person who came in and Corey Lewandowski
he was the phase one person who was
there orchestrating the big campaign
rallies that really launched Trump into
the stratosphere as a candidate and how
did man afford how was he able to
transform as what you described sort of
an unruly campaign into something that
had a lot more discipline and and how do
you carry that out so quickly and do you
think it was you know successful in your
estimation and he did win but there were
certainly stumbles along the way there
in the second part of the campaign well
Corey Lewandowski is an advanced man
mm-hmm
and for that period of the campaign
that's what was called for Paul Manafort
was able to call on a deep bench of
political associates going back through
many presidential campaigns to lend a
hand people with more experience at the
state level he was able to pull the very
best out of the existing Trump
organization to whip together an
organization going into the convention
to surmount the challenges there it's a
substantial task but the successful
nomination of Trump quashing the Ted
Cruz forces in the Rules Committee in
their attempt to try to hijack the
nomination demonstrated that he was
successful also I think though the
convention has to be viewed as what it
really is a television show mm-hmm it's
about entertainment and Paul Manafort
helped Donald Trump stage a very
successful convention the highlighting
of the Trump children the terrific
speech to rally the faithful by Rudy
Giuliani general Flynn's speech there
are a lot of high points in this
convention we have a larger audience for
our convention than the Democrats
unheard of and they pulled it out they
pull it together very quickly without
much structure so me and a Ford I think
gets and deserves and gets a lot of
credit in the book that's around the
time that you departed the campaign can
you talk about that a little bit and
what led to your leaving well I left in
August because my book on the Clintons
was coming out and I didn't want Trump
could be accused of
the secret you know progenitor of that
because he wasn't because I had a
fundamental disagreement on campaign
strategy at the time I mean I really
think I've already addressed it I think
he needed to run a more traditional
campaign and I did think that some of
the twitter fights that he got in
distracted from his overall message of
immigration and tax reform and and trade
and so on again he was right and I was
wrong about a lot of it but I also
appointed myself as the number one
surrogate for Donald Trump I probably
did five six hundred interviews or
surrogate speeches between the time I
left an election day because I felt I
knew the man for almost 40 years and I
could tell people firsthand why he would
be a great president why I was for about
his independence about his resilience
about his toughness so I never stopped
being a Donald Trump supporter but at 64
years old I wasn't going to be in a
campaign structure in which I had to
approve what I was going to write or say
mm-hmm
I felt I could be of greater help from
the outside and I think I was during the
convention there was a dramatic moment
when senator Cruz did not endorse Trump
on the stage he just told the voters
delegates to vote their instinct or
their conscience instead of voting for
Trump what was his response to that and
was that a surprise to you I think it
was a surprise to everyone in the
campaign because Paul Manafort had made
it clear to senator Cruz and to Jeff Roe
his manager that he didn't have to use
the word endorse but he had to say that
he was supporting Donald Trump and the
ticket this was I think one of the great
miss readings of politics if senator
Cruz thought that Trump was going to
lose and he clearly did the smart thing
to do would have been to do what Richard
Nixon did in 1964 when he was certain
the Goldwater was loose would lose give
him a full-throated endorsement and
campaigned for him every place that way
if Trump lost people would say good old
Ted
Kruse man he was really there for the
party he broke his back for the ticket
he gets consideration next time instead
Ted Cruz decided to be Nelson
Rockefeller take his ball and go home
hardcore conservatives and Trump
supporters will never let him be the
nominee of the party because he turned
his back on the party when the prospects
didn't look good now later on when he
figures out that Trump is likely to win
he endorsed his trunk too little too
late senator so I think he made an
enormous mistake I guess he thought that
the quality of his rhetoric would be so
great that it would be like the 1976
moment when Ronald Reagan addressed the
convention after Ford's nomination and
it was true many people in that
convention hall said my god
we have nominated the wrong man he's not
Ronald Reagan in fact he's more like
Richard Nixon
than Ronald Reagan what was Tron's
response was he surprised by that hurt
by it angry did he have any wish I think
he I think he was unhappy but he was
later on I think quite generous towards
the senator and I think he accepted his
later endorsement with good grace to had
gone back and forth and traded insults
there was Trump's declaration that Ted
Cruz's father had been in conversations
with the Kennedy assassin
and you write a little bit about that in
your book what do you make of that it
some people would say well why are we
talking about this it's not relevant
it's not but it you make it part of your
book can you talk about that a little
bit sure I believe that that Senator
Cruz's father did in fact know Lee Lee
Harvey Oswald Judith very Baker who is
indisputably an associate of Oswald
writes this in her book she said it in
multiple interviews the photograph you
seen comes from the Warren Commission
not from the National Enquirer I think
Donald Trump threw it out there to get
under Ted Cruz's skin and make him erupt
that was that was patriotism when in
fact even questioning his patriotism was
questioning his temperament
interesting look the question is obvious
why do people take an instantaneous
dislike to Ted Cruz they're merely
saving time so you feel like Trump's
tactics of trying to get an emotional
rise out of people on Twitter should he
do that now in the White House or should
he back off on that only for a strategic
purpose in this case he got Ted Cruz so
angry who was drooling you can see him
getting into a fight with a ten-year-old
boy in a rally so and the kid keeps
yelling lyin Ted lyin Ted buttocks in a
way you could argue backfire because
Cruz cited that as well as I think there
was some disparaging things said about
his wife Heidi as reasons why he was not
able to endorse Trump and we could argue
perhaps the Cruz endorsement might have
helped Trump at the convention Trump won
therefore I think senator Cruz is the
loser and his entire calculation look he
is a bush Republican masquerading as
something else and and I call him out
very extensively in the book you think
he'll survive a 28 trying to run again
in 2018 I would hope that somebody will
challenge him in the Republican primary
in Texas maybe the maybe the Attorney
General if not perhaps Alex Jones will
run who knows but somebody needs to
challenge him but if he survives that
and he has latent plans to run for
president I think many Republicans are
going to remember the fact that he
wouldn't endorse the ticket at the
convention you talked about some of your
favorite or most relevant passages in
the book that you find are you know work
really important to you that you want
people to take notice of sure Harry hurt
in his biography of Donald Trump and the
late Wayne Barrett who just passed away
recently of the village boys have both
written that a story that circulated
that indicated that Donald Trump was
scheduled to fly to Atlantic City from
New York and a helicopter that would
tragically crash in the Pinelands and
kill everybody aboard that that was made
up that down from
ever intended to be on that helicopter
that there was no plans but that he
promulgated the story to generate
favorable publicity I can tell you
firsthand that they're wrong
BuzzFeed Harry hurt Wayne Barrett
because I was working for Donald Trump
as a lobbyist working on currency
transaction issues I was in Washington
he was in New York I called him and said
I needed to see him as soon as possible
to go over some compromise language that
needed an approval immediately and he
said I can't see you today I've got to
go to Atlantic City I said I could jump
the shuttle and be there in an hour and
a half it's really important he said all
right I'll send the helicopter ahead and
hard to come back and pick me up I was
sitting in his office when Norma Federer
his longtime assistant came in and told
him that the superintendent of state
police in New Jersey Clint Pagano was on
the phone he put the veteran cop on the
speakerphone and he said mr. Trump I
have terrible news the helicopter your
company chartered has crashed and there
are no survivors and Donald said are you
absolutely sure
and Pagano said yes a hundred percent
and of course women were crying it was a
horrific time to his credit Donald
called every one of the widows right
then and there in some cases breaking
the news to them which I could never
have done so Donald Trump was telling
the truth now I am NOT claiming that I
saved his life I really believe that
this was an act of divine intervention
that this is bigger than than any one
person and at that point I decided that
God had spared Trump for a purpose some
future purpose we know what that know
what that purpose is very dramatic but
Trump was telling the truth about the
entire incident and he was smeared by
his critics
what a story Roger stone thanks for
being here the making of the President
2016 now available delighted to be here
Thanks